let's go back to that thing you were
mentioning let's see i think i have this
pull this up somewhere yes where we have
it from gravy and
uh great grabian news micah brzezinski
said this is february 22nd 2017.
our job is to control exactly what
people think
yeah they do yeah and and and what were
they telling everybody in 2008 just
before the big crash
everything's fine the economy is great
invest in the stock market go buy a
house go get yourself a loan
everything's hunky-dory and they knew
yeah what were they telling us in 2003
there's wmds weapons of mass destruction
they're working
osama bin laden is working with iraq
they're making
yellow cake and they're creating wet and
they're and they're creating little
small nuclear devices that will be
blowing up in new york city uh and then
we could go on we could we could go on
to
2001 when they told everyone the air was
safe to breathe down
at ground zero when it wasn't it was
filled with asbestos but the mainstream
media knowingly
that previously just a few months ago
was talking about the asbestos in the
twin towers
being white elephants just months ago
the new york times before 9 11 was
talking about that
they were now reporting the air is
completely safe to breathe
at ground zero even though it was filled
with asbestos and that criminality there
and you know i be i'm sure it's because
the local
law enforcement said that or the no no
chris
christie chrissy todd whitman announced
that after the epa got their results
fudged the data the data went through
condoleezza rice conde lisa rice edited
out that it was unsafe
that it was toxic that it was going to
kill people george w bush then published
the findings gave it out to the
mainstream media according with the epa
guidelines
and the epa announced the air is safe to
breathe even though they just
there you go you hear epa and that is
god to the media
yeah the media government says it is you
must if the government says it
you cannot question it unless that's my
experience i was in new york city i was
breathing in that dust
and i'm pissed all right unless unless
it's trump
when trump was the government everything
he said was false
so we get that 2003. we get that 2001 we
get that 2003.
we get that uh all throughout the you
know even katrina there was massive lies
and and total psyops there with what was
happening on the ground but look at last
october what what happened the new york
post put out a story hunter buy in his
laptop and social media shut the story
down
they said it was misinformation we can't
we can't allow this the spokesperson
from facebook goes on twitter
and says i'm blocking this information
these people
this is a religion this is cult-like
behavior
they don't care if it's true they just
the the the the
the priests of their new religion have
said it therefore they must act and they
shut the news
down then what happens after the
election oh that laptop story
oh that was true yeah yeah like the
media is going to tell you the truth and
the wuhan lab story which they were
contradicting and now they're
contradicting themselves once again with
you know the admissions and the data
that's killers
clearly suggests that another thing i
wanted to bring up along with the golden
handcuffs
kind of analogy is what happened to
jesse van cura because he has an amazing
story of working for msnbc
in 2003 where he was rightly
anti-war he was against the war in
afghanistan he says there's no way i
will support it msnbc bought him a
full-time
show that he was supposed to do five
days a week and they asked him you're
going to be pro-war he said nope
what what happened he ended up finishing
his contract by not doing a single show
and he got a whole bunch of money for
lock you down
yeah they locked him down he couldn't
say anything about it during that year
he couldn't do any interviews about it
they controlled every aspect of his
existence we even i i can't believe
we're saying this but but even chen
yuger had horrible experiences in msnbc
with them trying to control
i mean if you're trying to control
chanky huger now and what
and what his talking points are and he
even came out rightfully so against
msnbc i mean wow you got
you got a major problem when it comes to
controlling the narrative controlling
the agenda
with closely psychologically approved
written talking points that are meant to
have an effect that effect predominantly
is
horrible for the general public and
really good for the special interests
for the billionaire class
and the multinational globalists that
benefit off of these horrible policies
that hurt people more than they help
them
one thing that people need to understand
about how these newsrooms work is that
when we hear this story about jesse
ventura people think that
some big boss is coming down to the
employees and saying you will report as
i tell you or else
that happens certainly but often what
they do is they just recruit people they
know to be either docile
or who already believe in the certain
ideology or agenda they're pushing
so they will go to they'll see someone
tweeting a bunch like tweeting nonstop
about palestine
saying israel is bad then they'll come
to them and say you're a really great
reporter would you like to be our middle
east reporter
knowing this person will frame every
story as anti-israel or pro-palestine
the inverse is true in many regards
depends on what the corporate entity
wants what kind of idea they want to
push
why bother hiring someone and then
trying to bribe them to say lies
when you could find someone who's
already willing to lie or is just really
dumb
anyway and they'll just say what you
want to be said
well at fox 26 every every word
that i would say on air was pre-approved
by my boss lee
first so there was there was no
tightly written scripts oh yeah so yeah
i would i would be sent out to cover a
story
i would write a script of of what i was
going to say on tv yeah
and then i would send it to her and she
would make changes if she wanted to and
send the script back to me and that's
what i would say on twitter
so this is happening on local news
imagine the bigger effects on national
news
i mean you could only imagine the level
of control that goes through there
so so you worked for fox corp
which is not fox news uh right i mean
fox news and fox
corp are both owned by the murdochs okay
but uh uh you know they're owned by uh
rupert murdoch lachlan murdoch is in
charge of fox corp that's rupert's son
and fox corp has the the fox sports
uh i believe fox sports and then and all
the fox local owned stations
so so it is still similar in that regard
it's a murdoch company
yeah you'd think that the media would be
cheering for you calling out
fox right like these leftists that uh
say the daily beast would be saying
wow you've you've exposed the murdochs
for who they really are
trying to force you to lie or withhold
information
that's not what they're doing it's
really weird so i guess i'll just say it
i think you made the mistake of
giving an interview to the daily beast
right is that what happened oh yeah
i mean i was being blown the media was
blowing me up on uh
monday i guess it was and i i guess
yeah tuesday and anyway i was just like
oh i was like looking at all these
emails and i was like looking
at what i reckon oh i recognize the name
daily beast that's a media outlet okay
sure yeah i'll talk here's my number and
and then uh this lady
we had a very nice conversation and then
uh
later someone's like oh there's a daily
beast article okay i see the headlines
i i when i saw the headline i instantly
knew it was a spirit piece
i haven't even read the article if if i
i'm not interested in smear piece i
don't care
if someone wants to write a smear
whatever uh because i knew i know who i
am
but uh it's just okay i wasted my time
on her whatever i think i have the smear
piece pulled up i could be wrong it says
wait
this is why a local fox reporter
sabotaged her career
ivory hacker told the daily beast on
tuesday that she's been terminated after
claiming on air the station has muzzled
her
this is an opinion piece yeah i didn't
even tell her i had been terminated i
told her this weird situation that
happened where
my bosses wouldn't tell me why they were
getting my
asking for my gear back and then i
received a text from a third party
saying that my boss told
him to tell me and i was like okay this
is this is weird and these people are so
nice to you and they're so encouraging
and they're so friendly and they're so
supportive
when they talk to you when they
interview you and then the stuff they
write your eyeballs pop out i mean we
were hanging out
around a couple journalists and like you
know we talked privately i was like that
guy's so full of utter
i can't say it here family friend you're
being vague because
this you're describing their situation
there's there's many of them and then
and a lot of them are like that guy's
gonna write the most horrible horrendous
hit piece
ever he is this is a disgusting
soul energy vampire and then people
around me people around me i know you're
talking about
that one girl she's like no they're
gonna be great he's such a nice guy he's
so friendly i'm like you could
you could feel and sense energy when
you're in tuned with it
and you just smell the scumbaggery
through a lot of these low-life
psychopathic individuals that have sick
twisted personalities that try to
befriend you
in this fake sick way in order to try to
destroy you
and and it's convincing a lot of people
who aren't who aren't like
experienced in this larger kind of
psychological
uh crazy trauma abuse that that they're
through
they're victims of it i'll i'll reveal
uh a little bit
about um this one situation i think luke
may be referring to
there was a point where uh this
journalist who had agreed to an
interview
left a wireless microphone um
and active at a table and saying bye
i'll see y'all later and people are
still sitting around
and it seemed like it was
meant to catch audio off the record when
we when he left
so he could record all of our
conversations i'm like there's a hot
microphone
a wireless hot microphone i forgot who
found it but i was absolutely
furious about it because who goes into
your home and leaves a hot microphone
inside of your home uh essentially
wiretapping us
uh when when we were having private
conversations but but
the response was oh it was just an
accident we forgot it was there it's no
big deal
and so i'm not i'm not implying anything
by it i'll also uh say
it's it's it's not that i'm condemning
that completely outright
because like project veritas does
undercover reporting
but there there is something different
about you agreeing to sit down with a
journalist
who then tries to sneak a you know
microphone into your
into your house versus you get caught
undercover but i'm i'm not trying to
make that i'm not trying to act like
they're completely different
but the issue is this guy came in with
an agenda we knew he had an agenda he
was extremely weasley and it was very
obvious the way he was asking questions
the way he was framing things
and too many people are are trusting of
these people to think
so i'll put it i'll put it this way when
when your video comes out project
veritas what did the fox 26 say they
said it was a
falsely deceptively edited video and
misinformation or whatever
and that's what i hear from a
disgruntled former employee
implying that be because i was fired by
fox i'm doing this everyone knows that's
false i did what i did live on tv
while i was working for fox so it's an
obvious false statement from fox
why would they make themselves look so
bad but so
you know what they try they try to make
that claim
that when you actually hear people
saying these words that they're
deceptively editing or whatever what
these journalists do
is they mission they mishmash quotes
from you so they can claim you literally
said them
and then they can publish whatever they
want they can use various tricks
so that i can take a quote from you and
then i can edit
dot dot and take a different quote and
mash them together so it makes it sound
like you believe in the same things
they do that they do it all the time
people don't realize it because they
assume the media must be telling the
truth
it is easy to do there was a famous
comedian caught doing this in australia
with uh the reporter for uh ivy i forgot
uh his exactly oh right right right
right right
he secretly recorded the interview and i
had many media publications come to be
like we want to do an interview i'm like
okay
i'm gonna record it too as soon as i say
that no that guy that we were just
referring to
was an absolute liar he did a huge hit
piece
uh we don't even want to mention him by
name we don't want to give him any more
attention
but but but again a lot of major
mainstream publications yeah major
mainstream publications and and they're
so i i smell these guys out like a
bloodhound because because it's so
telling it's it's so true and
and you must have to be like i i it's
just hard to believe a lot of people
have it
i'll give you anything they wouldn't do
they wouldn't do it themselves
i wouldn't do something that they were
doing i'll give you a i'll give you a
personal example and i'll call out the
journalist by name
andrew morantz he came to do an
interview with me at my apartment
writing for i think this was the new
yorker yeah as the new yorker
and i told him this big long story you
know
i was talking for quite some time he
recorded actually he took one story
where i had a quote and a different
story with a different quote
and he put him together it's gorgeous to
make completely different context
when vice cause because it was about
vice
saw the quote they got mad and said that
is not true that quote isn't true
so the so what new yorker did was they
removed it but instead of admitting
fault
they said a quote from tim poole has
been removed because it contained errors
it wasn't my error but then what
happened was many people in media
started saying tim lied and provided
false quotes to the new yorker
because the new yorker should have come
out and said andrew marantz
andrew marantz is a lying two-faced
duplicitous
fake reporter who makes things up and
then doesn't
correct himself they could have done
that he could have said i'm sorry i made
a mistake and i miss
me i wrote down no type i was in
accident i i talked to him on the phone
and i said bro
you have a recording of this you came to
my house you turned the recorder on
and he was like too bad and i'm like
dude
the story i told you i've told on my
youtube channel before
the story that i told you i have told
numerous times
the quotes you mash together in no way
reflect the story i've told
and he was like well what we said about
removing it was was fair and true
it contained errors and i said yeah your
errors so put that it was your error and
he goes we're not going to do that
well yup welcome to the media and then
he's writing this like trivial
meaningless
drama that has absolutely no merit on
any real life
or or anybody's else existence and i'm
like
how do you call yourself a journalist
like how do you look at yourself in the
mirror
i know i know but but it's just hard to
fathom how someone could be
so duplicitous i had the southern
poverty poverty law center do the same
thing about me
take two different statements pull pull
them together
as if i was calling for a violent
revolution when i was specifically
calling for a non-violent evolution of
people waking up
informing themselves and helping out
their fellow brothers and sisters and
starting communities
they took two separate quotes put them
together as if i called for a violent
revolution and they put that on their
website
and they put me a part of their patriot
hit list and i'm like
i'm like oh my god like i never said
this
i recorded a conversation there's a
video there's a youtube video that they
took it from
and and the two exact quotes are in two
different positions and you just
conflated it to try to make me look like
somebody i'm not
so that is deceptive editing yeah and
what project veritas is doing is not
deceptive editing and the new sound
bytes i just put out today
a ton of direct from their own lips my
bosses
uh it spells out there was no
deceptive editing in what project
project veritas just released
okay go go listen to my new video it's
not real news anymore they are
corporations that seek to make money off
of infotainment
so project veritas a a non-profit
doesn't make money off infotainment it
makes money off of exposing corruption
there you can argue that like the
southern poverty law center oh they make
money when they get these stories
accusing people of being racist oh
project veritas makes money when they
can
accuse someone of malfeasance i suppose
the difference is that project veritas
puts out videos where people's mouths
are moving
whereas southern poverty law center just
writes whatever they want kind of makes
things up actually
i will say outright makes things up they
had to retract an article about me and
a bunch of other leftists which is
really funny they claimed i love it i
love it southern poverty law center you
guys deserve this one
they claimed that i was alt-right i'm as
most people know it's a meme because i
say i'm mixed race so often
and so i'm definitely not and they
claimed that i went to a holocaust
deniers conference in iran
which is like the most insane thing to
accuse someone of doing
like there's sanctions on this country
it's very difficult for americans to go
there
what are you talking about well it turns
out their source for this
was a conspiracy theory website for
holocaust deniers
that had been deleted and someone
archived
and the southern poverty law center
thought that was a credible source
to publish on their hate watch or
whatever and accuse me of actually going
there
and i remember talking to a lawyer on
the phone he's like now this is
important
you know if there's going to be a
defamation case here you need to tell me
if you've ever
if you've if you've actually gone to
something like this or is there any way
that this could be construed as just his
opinion on the matter and i was like
i've never been to iran this is insane
it was a conspiracy theory website
and he's like okay all right and then
the southern poverty law center had to
retract that
their their goal is just to make money
off of shotcom and here's the really sad
thing is that the media puts a lot of
weight on
what the southern poverty law center
says when i was with the nbc affiliate
in minneapolis
uh there was a story uh that i was uh
there was a
actually anti-jihad protest happening
that i was assigned to
and the group who was protesting jihad
the the southern poverty
law center had listed as a terrorist
group i guess
or or a hate group and uh and so
my my tv station actually told me don't
go interview them we don't want to give
a hate group
you know time time of day on camera so
because this little law center said
that this group is a hate group they
were about to get
zero air time they couldn't even explain
themselves why they were protesting
jihad and so i objected i was like
absolutely not i'm going to interview
the people
doing this protest and i'm going to
interview the people they're protesting
and i'm going to show exactly both sides
and i and when i put it together i
had both sides going back and forth and
it was incredibly compelling
and it turns out these these people were
protesting the abuse of children their
abuse
protesting child marriages they were
protesting oppression of women
that's what these people were protesting
they were they were doing the opposite
of hate they're they were standing up
for women's rights
uh this group which by the way because
jihad uh
there's different layers of jihad uh
some people
it's it's there's different layers but
they were protesting the
the radical jihad that's they were
taking a stand against it so
but anyway i went and i went and
interviewed the islamic group that that
stands firmly with jihad too
it was very interesting story but i had
to put my foot down on that story
but a lot of reporters and news people
are pushovers you wanna
they don't wanna interject and say that
i wanna that i wanna interview this
person
because god forbid that oh she likes to
give hate groups the time of day no
we're trying to get to the bottom of the
truth on this now when i worked for
fusion
there was a pitch from one of our
producers they wanted to go and film a
clan
training like like actual clan members
of which there's very few there's a few
thousand in the country remaining i
think
and people at fusion said we don't want
to give a hate group
coverage it's bad well vice ended up
doing something similar
they embedded with a bunch of alt-right
and white nationalists in
charlottesville and won a bunch of
awards for it
they actually had a reporter go into the
hotel room of white nationalists
allow these white nationalists to say
any and everything
and they won an award for it so long as
you are part of their cult
and you and and it for whatever reason
they accept it then you get to do it but
if you challenge them in any way
if you're not bending the knee to their
indoctrination then they'll remove you
and say you can't
it's just i feel like the media is so
easily manipulated i think there's a lot
of
innocent naive media members who don't
realize they're being
manipulated by groups like the southern
poverty law center
who who was a yeah peer pressuring them
into not talking to people who
were actually standing up for people for
individuals rights
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you